poutine s'entretiendront en vision
conférence demain moscou aimerait avoir
l'assurance que l'otan ne va pas
continuer à s'étendre vers l'est en
particulier avec une adhésion de
l'ukraine il sera aussi question du
déploiement militaire russe à la
frontière ukrainienne les sujets de
tension sont donc nombreux nous nous
intéressons ce matin la région du
dombass situe entre l'ukraine et la
russie elle est déchirée par une guerre
responsable de la mort de plus de dix
mille personnes depuis 2014 nos envoyés
spéciaux gilbert craag maria vert et
nico va et elena volochine se sont
rendus sur les positions de l'armée
ukrainienne avdic à
l' usine à charbon d'actifs qu'un
maintenu la ville ukrainienne sur la
ligne de front à flot tout au long de la
guerre
ici on préfère d'ailleurs ne pas parler
du conflit
j'essaie de ne pas regarder les
nouvelles la ville en est assez dur
comme ça
pourtant le sud de la ville est dévastée
par les combats
l'armée ukrainienne tient ses positions
dans les usines aux ruines
ici les échanges de tirs sont quasi
quotidiens l'ennemi est à moins de 100
mètres pour ceux dont 1,6 ghz ils n'ont
pas de suite dans les idées ils peuvent
tirer n'importe quoi n'importe quoi pour
cet officier la question d'une invasion
de l'ukraine par la russie est caduque
si
la russie est déjà en territoire
ukrainien les sacs ont besoin d'autres
preuves lorsqu'on capture un prisonnier
de guerre et qu'il un passeport russe
pourtant ces soldats ne s'attendent pas
à une escalade majeure
il dit sans arrêt qu'il va y avoir une
attaque que les russes hamas leur force
c'est pour ça que je n'y crois pas il
subirait de trop grosses pertes
la ligne de front dans le dos de bath
n'a pas bougé de manière significative
depuis bientôt 7 ans mais la situation
reste instable tant que la russie
n'accepte pas l'orientation pro
occidentale de l'ukraine et l'ukraine
n'accepte pas l'occupation d'une partie
de son territoire par les forces du
kremlin
à cinq kilomètres de la ligne de front
new york une ville belle et bien
ukrainienne et les membres de ces
centres communautaires qui tout comme
les américains s'inquiètent la
concentration des troupes russes à la
frontière connu cela n'aide phone avec
ce qui se passe entendre que ça risque
de devenir encore pire c'est dur mais
cette année de guerre déjà assez dur tom
six mille étoiles n'est pas aux jo
et maintenant nous sommes conscients que
ça va durer encore très longtemps je
souhaite accompagner moigne on en a pour
toute notre vie
dans cette ville les derniers
bombardements sur les quartiers habités
remonte à 2019
la présidentielle en france hier